hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close I'm Geo
and um
he's looking at us like the [__] what if
they're actually just saying my name
oh there's so many things named Bart
yeah Bay Area Transit there's that one
and there's like Barts like systems and
there's Parts like town I'm like there's
no giovannas there's no GEOS I went to
Italy I didn't see much of that they
want cool stuff
or just easy [__] huh the Saint
Bartholomew's yeah yeah like there's not
that many Louis Vuittons and Gucci's
like I get it you know jovanas we belong
there everyone owns a Louis Vuitton yeah
but
they're very unique okay what are you
trying to say
I don't know I'm just trying to like
beat you at your [__] well you can't
I know you're full of it I get it see
you win so recently I asked uh Instagram
um what are some topics you might want
us to talk about yeah and one of them I
thought um was pretty good because I
remember like you know no one is built
confident or born confident you know
yeah and so one of the questions was
like how do you build your own belief
how do you build your own confidence
um and like when do you know you have it
like how did that all come about
um so that was a question yeah I think
you're actually super qualified to
answer that I feel like you're someone
that has always believed in yourself and
no one else did
and like
um I'm someone that
either put on this facade or just knew I
was confident
for that thing that I was being tested
in
um and I had to learn how to build my
own personal confidence within myself
because I think I I functioned as
someone that had a huge chip on her
shoulder yeah so I had to constantly I I
felt at least obviously right like I put
myself in this light like um
this judgment that people were placing
me on that they probably weren't that
I'm like I have to like rise to the
occasion every single [__] time so
that people know why do you think people
are judging you or like why do you yeah
why did you perceive it like that
um because I had the chip on the
shoulder where what do you think that
chip came from I think it came from my
upbringing I think it came from
me being a middle child and like
constantly having to prove my worth and
that sounds really [__] up and it
really wasn't like that but kind of like
I'm I wasn't I don't think as a
conscious it's probably subconscious yes
I wasn't I wasn't
the firstborn right like I'm not the
oldest nor am I the first male
um and I'm not the youngest so my oldest
sister is the oldest of the four then
next to her is my brother who's the only
male and in a Hispanic household like
the male is like what they seek because
that's going to carry the lineage the
family name blah blah blah
then you have the baby that everyone
takes care of because they're the baby
you know and then the middle child is
usually the one that like
it's kind of overlooked a little bit
would you say the middle child and
middle children are kind of the same so
whether you have three to seven is
they're all middle children I don't know
seven sounds pretty gnarly I don't know
how that works I don't know how those
Dynamics are always the oldest and the
youngest and then so regardless if it's
three or five you know these are the
middle children possibly I don't know
how it works the more children you have
but I feel like the oldest to the
youngest are Polar Opposites yeah they
have specials right because the oldest
is the one that gets the younger parents
the drilling constantly then the next
one comes and the first one's helping
raise the second one and then when it
comes to the youngest one the parents
are usually more experienced not as like
um not as not involved but they've
loosened up a little bit like if the
pacifier falls on the floor like if it
was your first kid you don't know yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know like we're
trying to disinfect everything but then
with the baby now we're just like it's
okay like they're Built Tough yeah so I
don't know what that's like
um I just know for myself I started
realizing how I was functioning and it
got me far you know operating with this
trip on my shoulder because
um I was constantly trying to prove my
worth and trying to prove why I deserve
to be in the room whichever room I was
in or in that position and then the
older and the more mature I got I was
able to realize that that wasn't
necessarily like the best way to
function just because when I don't rise
up to the occasion so much is tied to
that identity that I'm like [__] I
really failed like I would get really
down on myself because I felt like I
disappointed so many people when was a
time where you got down on yourself a
lot uh my all my 20s like when though
like looking in an instance like what
was an occasion you had to rise up to
and then you're like [__] I fell short
um
whenever I was put like in a leadership
position I felt like they gave me a
specific one
I don't know
um this was like so long ago
uh
um let's say I was
okay something as simple as like me
producing a show right like I'm not
given any real outlines like no one
really told me these are your guidelines
this is you the parameters you work in
it was just me
pitching an idea and then people going
like okay yeah that works let's do that
and then if it doesn't come out like if
the numbers come back and it wasn't what
I wanted it to be then I'm like holy
[__] I'm a [__] idiot I should get
fired I'm the worst I didn't live up to
my potential like I let my whole team
down like holy [__] they're gonna see
I'm such a [__] loser I'm not as
qualified you know like I felt like um
um I felt like a phony
and how do you feel now about that now
it's now it's different because I've
matured right like now me putting so
much on other people to get my
validation just doesn't make sense it
just doesn't it it just that's when I
knew I was maturing because I'm like
that's not fair to the other person to
put so much on them to like give me
feedback about myself do you feel like
there is ever a time when that's
necessary yes because you know when
you're like three I don't know if you're
gonna be like I don't need validation
from others it's all about myself yeah
but I think the way I did it was not as
um it wasn't healthy like there's always
a time and place right like you can be
the most confident person in the world
but if you're not seeking out others for
information or uh humbling yourself to
learn from other people then you're just
an Arrogant Bastard that's gonna end up
by themselves yeah right like it takes
you're not you're not an island you
can't function by yourself you need to
learn how to collaborate and know when
it is your role to like step up to the
plate or go hey you know what this is
out of my field of expertise I need to
step back and I need to let other people
kind of steer the ship here yeah
um but the way I was operating before
it was I'm I know it all like I I need
to like hold my own I can't ask for help
because I should know what the hell's
going on
and it's just putting so much
um it's putting like it kind of would
put myself down like I I didn't have
um
it it seemed like I didn't have like
full grasp of who I was and what my
abilities were and I would wait for
other people to tell me like dude you're
badass in this and I'd be like oh yeah
am I oh cool thank you I didn't know
that you know where now I'm going okay
I'm actually pretty cool in this you
know like I think I'm all right in it
what what changed
I think I just kept getting hurt I kept
getting sad when things wouldn't turn
out how I expected them to which is
normal which I think things don't
necessarily always turn out the way you
plan it because it can't you can't
predict the future but then when it
wouldn't come out how I wanted it to
come out then I would get down and I'm
like wait this is not a cool feeling I
don't like feeling like this I don't
like putting this on even as something
as simple like as our relationship right
like if I felt I wasn't living up to
um the partner that I felt that you
needed me to be then I felt like I was
doing you a disservice
it's interesting why because uh I'm
trying I've been listening the whole
time and I'm like
I don't think I've ever experienced any
of what you've experienced yeah I know
that's why I said I think this topic is
really going to be big for you well for
me it's always been like
I know what a through f is what does
that mean for everything what does that
mean a b c d f I know you [__] I
know the alphabets but how does that ABC
I'm gonna kick you in the face like um
like you know A is for apples
and B is for oranges
and C is for carrots
and D is four that mic is in such an
enticing position right now all I need
to do is extend my leg and connect do
you understand great I do okay so as a
kid I felt like I just knew the scale
for everything like if the teacher said
this is the project I'll go okay in my
brain I know what a looks like what an F
looks like or if I'm supposed to do this
I know what Kung Fu a through F looks
like or if I someone if my mom made food
oh I know what an a pizza looks like and
taste should tastes like and I know what
an F1 should look like and taste like I
just felt like I just knew so when I did
something
if I as soon as I was done like okay I'm
done I looked at it I can go I'm
probably gonna get a c on this or I'm
gonna get an A so I it's it's always
been unattached it's not like here can
you grade it and then they grade it I go
oh man the ah man already happened with
me because I would look at something I'm
like
this is a [__] f
and then if I turn it in I'll just be
like it's it's not like uh I don't need
someone to grade it I can just tell like
almost every second of my life I can
tell if I'm doing good or bad yeah I
think you just didn't grow up I mean
obviously I think this comes from my
upbringing where I was just constantly
bullied and everything I did was stupid
or [__] like that those are my names
when I grew up I see and I'm not trying
to be like oh baby oh like it it did
what it had to do right like I love
where I'm at now so maybe because of
that yourself for sure [__] maybe
but ten people clown on you so it's like
super [__] my a is actually maybe a f
super fast I see it's super super [__]
because I shouldn't be seeking outside
validation right yeah
um at least from everybody I think it's
okay to seek validation from an expert
or someone you look up to but when
you're constantly being talked down to
and like my no one would ever call me by
not my parents but like no one would
ever call me by my name it was always
like hey you [__] or hey you dumbass
or hey you stupid [__] like it was that
way yeah yeah
um and after a while you grow with thick
skin right and you're just like okay
these are words and like obviously you
give power to these words and it's up to
you how it affects you or whatever but
that comes with maturity and that comes
with understanding yeah but growing up
um
it's it's like this roller coaster right
because like as you're as you're
becoming as you're leaving chat like
being a child or from being a child like
in your childhood to becoming an
adolescent and I'm becoming a teenager
to an adult like it molds you you know
and and like
um I did look up to my brother and
sister and stuff and I would seek that
validation because I I loved them so
much I looked up to them so much but
they're the ones that are clowning on me
and I love them and I don't blame them
for anything and they're the best
[__] people ever
um and we have such a great relationship
now but growing up I mean they didn't
know any better either they're also
little kids but like it really does [__]
with you you know like you you grow up
having a lot of self-doubt so like I
didn't even know I was operating this
way I would just see myself
exceeding in certain spaces and I didn't
even really understand why
isn't that crazy what's in it what's a
space that you exceeded in just in like
with you guys right like doing JK like
we started doing well like I held high
level positions because I clearly proved
my skill set right I proved my value
yeah but like I didn't understand and he
still would be like I don't know if I'm
doing good 100 you know like I always
felt like there was someone else better
qualified I'm like well why not that
person why is it me like I don't think I
don't think I'm better than that person
like I never felt like I was better than
anyone else I was just like oh maybe I
just have a slight Edge you know and and
at any point where like
um they see that this Edge is either a
facade or they misrepresented the slight
Edge that I have then I'm gonna easily
be replaced damn that's crazy I know I
know and it wasn't until like I always
thought I was better than everyone else
that's what I'm saying you had this
confidence you know I remember in
biology like this is even like an elac
and this is me like spending five years
in high school I still thought I was
better than everyone else I was I was
just like a teacher's fault they don't
know how to go I just not need to apply
myself but I know like I'm like I'm this
LS3 Chevelle but you had a mom that
needs a new paint job and I just need to
oil change but you just wait once you
get my [__] internals I'm gonna be
700 horses dude you had this mom that
would beat the [__] out of you right but
the way you tell me that she would speak
about you and how what standard you're
supposed to be in I never had that
conversation I didn't even know that
there were levels like that I see like
she would speak like you were her pride
and joy I didn't have that I was I was
raised to be like a medieval Prince no
that's amazing I didn't have any of that
my parents were too goddamn busy yeah
You Walk This Way you sit this way not
at all communicate this way no it was
more I did I had none of that yeah there
was no set there was no like you need to
be a queen of this thing at some point
right now you're a princess that needs
to become a queen it was just like we
don't have time for you
just make sure you're doing what your
teacher tells you to do you need to pass
are you fed are you healthy cool that's
all I have time for we got it we got to
keep the ship moving you know so
um I didn't have anyone stroking my ego
not to say that
I mean your [__] is pretty [__] too
but for me it was something that I
really had to battle like crazy when was
your first taste of confidence there
where it started like the the ship start
turning around
so for me it came in spurts like it was
it was minor Spirits so the most
superficial spurt it came in when I
started feeling attractive like that was
the most superficial but it was one of
the most confident boosting thing when
everyone was like wow you're actually
really attractive when was that
um College oh yeah so in high school you
thought you're ugly for sure because I
wasn't the popular chick I didn't date
the coolest guys you know I didn't like
no one was like at least that I knew no
one was like like oh we gotta like get
with Geo right but it wasn't until I
went into college where it was like oh
[__] like damn who's that girl who's
that who's that who's that who's that is
that and I was like oh [__] superficial
as [__] but it was a it was a a
confidence boost that I had never felt
because growing up I was
they rag on your appearance you know
like you're like I had a gap teeth and
like it's just ragging after ragging
after ragging so it's like you don't
think you're anything
um so that gives you a boost in some
regard yeah you know what it allows you
to walk into a space and kind of have a
straighter stiffer back yeah but again
it's short-lived it's super superficial
it doesn't go very far but that was one
of the first times I started feeling
that you know that was one of the things
my mom would emphasize a little bit
um was that she's like oh like you know
one of your business cards is always
going to be your appearance you know
which is very true because like in most
sales positions
they emphasize looks so much because you
almost feel the way you look yeah you
know if you're wearing pajamas you kind
of just feel you feel like Bed Head yeah
but like the minute you go to a suit
store and they put that suit on you and
then it just drapes on you got the tie
on and you got like the slightly
elevated dress shoes you're just like oh
[__] like looking a milk you just look a
million bucks and then you feel a
million books and there's nothing that
changed about your actual appearance you
just put some things on
but now you carry yourself like maybe
more professionally or more proper or
whatever you know yeah yeah
um it does matter a lot as like because
I think people downplay vanity a lot ah
it's so superficial whatever but it's
like you're outside yeah I don't know
about how you feel on the inside yeah I
guess it's a it's a I don't know why
it's a it's a topic that people kind of
like want to like sweep under the rug
but it's like they're we all know it's
an advantage yeah like we all know like
that's where they say sex sells right
like no it just dictates in general like
you know when we tie taika's hair into a
ponytail on top of his head he's already
silly goose but he's three times more
silly Goosey once you can see himself in
the mirror like the outside effects are
insides a lot yeah so that was one of
the first tastes the other one would be
um I started getting confidence when I
was able to support myself
when I was able to um pay for my own
College uh graduate college move out of
my house this is pre pre-career just
like my career just like one-off jobs
here and there yeah yeah yeah I was I
didn't have too many jobs it was just
like the bank job yeah but I was
excelling there so much that I was
getting promoted making decent money
um live on my own
um you know still get my parents respect
and have their back so that was a
different confident booster the more
capability booster of like oh [__] yeah
okay cool like you can't knock me off my
block because I made this block I
[__] I chopped down the tree and I I
uh molded it I like [__] chipped away
at it this is my [__] so no one could
take that away from me so that's a
different type of confidence but when it
came uh into when it went into more of
the business realm something I had never
done where I'm leading people or I'm
like leading initiatives or coming up
with these initiatives like that one I
was just like what the [__] I do not
belong here I don't know what the [__]
I'm doing because it wasn't something
that um
I don't know it just felt like uh yeah I
just felt lost the whole time and I'm
like and I'm I'm someone that needed the
feedback because I'm so unsure right
because I was telling you the way I was
raised it was like they're [__]
ragging on you all the time yeah so it's
like I don't know what I'm doing and I'm
like [__] is this okay like [__] I don't
I don't know I need some feedback like
what's going on yeah
um but the older you get the more you're
like wait you're not gonna get this
feedback like you're you need to be your
own feedback you need to see what the
standard is and see if
you you can uh if you're even there kind
of like your abcdf stuff but I didn't
know that
and what would you say was like
bam full-blown Geo I'm confident now
uh um
I think it would be
are you still not confident no I'm
pretty confident now yeah yeah for sure
come you always want me to like whisper
like sweet things to you in your ear
when is this like all the time when was
the last time I'll say something you're
like tell me tell me more tell me more
about oh you did a really good job with
this oh I like what you did with that my
mind you're like tell me more tell me
more I'm gonna know I'm done like no you
gotta tell me it's cute I think it's
cute also you don't need this I don't
need it I don't need it but it's always
nice like who doesn't like a compliment
right
but if you didn't compliment me I'd be
like oh I I'm doing okay you don't need
me to do this whisper they'll sweep
yeah well now I'm what I'm I'm 39. I
think I started getting my real
confidence like I guess it's more so in
the business space
right because as a as like a person I'm
pretty confident
like as myself like as who I am like as
my morals and like
um I'm pretty confident in myself like I
know I'm a great person I know I'm a
trustworthy person I know I'm like
um an asset to people in their life yeah
but maybe it's more so in like the
business space because it's something
that was so new for me yeah that um it
wasn't until maybe I was
35.
36 37 I forgot when wow like recently it
took a minute to get confident [__] yeah
because I I had this Narrative of like
you don't know what you're doing like
what are you doing like yeah like you're
just winging it all the time that's
pretty crazy because I'm pretty sure
from the outside you know you probably
looked confident the whole 10 years
you're doing JK and barbell people
probably from the outside temperature so
confident she's building the gym she's
doing all this yeah and I'm going like
on the inside I'm like this is I just
hope it doesn't [__] fail I'm just
I'm like I just don't know like whatever
I'm doing hasn't failed yet so I'm just
slightly tweaking it every time but the
whole time I was just nervous like when
I would produce a sketch right and it's
a little sketch but for us it's our
bread and butter so it is a big deal
yeah
um I'm producing this sketch from
literally paper to the actual live
filming of
the product we're going to put out for
the masses to see yeah
um every day like on that from the
beginning of when it's released to me to
when it goes live that whole time I'm
losing my [__] I'm so [__]
self-conscious I'm so nervous I can't
eat like when it like the night before
we have to shoot it the day of the shoot
I'm like a [__] wreck cause I'm like
holy [__] it can all go to [__] yeah
yeah I I think I just live with high
anxiety man sure do yeah but it wasn't
until I started really doing I Guess the
Shadow work as people like to talk about
it and going well wait where does this
stem from like why do I need so much
outside validation like why do I care
about
people's opinions about me I think it's
okay to care about people's opinions but
it it really matters who these opinions
like what mouths they're coming out of
yeah like if it's someone that's not in
a position where you want to be like why
would it matter yeah you know their
shit's all [__] up yes it's like
you're not gonna take Financial advice
from someone who's like five billion
dollars in debt literally yeah right but
even then I would still take something
from that and I think to a certain
degree it's okay
um because there's things that they
might say that might trigger something
else in you to make these connections
for yourself yeah but
um yeah I just started really going like
wait what am I doing like who am I like
what am I made out of like if [__] were
to hit the fan like what am I confident
that I can nail it at and then at that
point it was like oh [__] okay this is
this is what I'm good at what would you
tell your now that you're your
confidence self what would you tell your
like super not confident self is there
any pieces of advice you would tell me
if you were able to travel back in time
and meet them
yeah I would be like be a [__] better
friend to yourself
like be like like I remember boosting up
a lot of my friends yeah and like
cheering them on and just being like yo
you got this like what the [__] like you
know that pep talk yeah yeah yeah I just
didn't have that with myself it was the
opposite like you suck you can't do this
yeah like it was like like dude like you
shouldn't be here or you shouldn't do
that or damn that's really [__] or
that's really stupid or that's you know
why are you doing that
um or like are you sure you want to do
that like I had to fight myself a lot
and that's when I came up with my whole
[__] it let's do it like because I just
knew when I would get into my own head
yeah that I had to stop it before it got
to
too extreme to where I would talk myself
out of things so I had to just be like
as soon as I felt any inkling of like
negativity
coming back at me I had to be like [__]
it let's do it don't think about it
you know so it maybe from the outside it
looked like I was very impulsive for
certain things in my life yeah but it
was because I just I knew if I talked to
myself it was gonna divert me in the
wrong direction
you know what's crazy
what you just explained like your
journey to confidence is what a lot of
gurus call the ace method what's that so
appearance capability expansion just
kidding I just made that up right now
but flipping him off why because you're
a [__] no but I called it the eight
the A Smith that's [__] fast that's
really good you know why because a lot
of uh of these like mentors and gurus
the first thing they want their clients
to do is get in shape if you feel slow
you feel sluggish you feel lazy and you
don't have that 5 a.m initiative
that's how you're going to apply
yourself to everything in life right oh
your daughter's crying you don't just
get up out like what the hell is going
on let's fix this you don't have that
let's fix this right now you know it's
more like uh when you move through life
like what five miles an hour and you
solve problems five miles an hour and
like your house is burning down and you
let half of the thing like but your dog
catch on fire before you leave the house
right
so first thing is fix your appearance
you can do that quick you can lose a lot
of weight short amount of time and you
know you're a different creature you
look you feel different you make
decisions differently now you build the
capability before you're like oh [__] I
could only run a mile and 20 minutes
after you fix yourself your joints feel
good like oh [__] I'm doing like six
seven minute miles cool I learned how to
build myself now how do I use the same
tools I just did in a short amount of
time in like two to three months how do
I expand that into other areas of my
life business family Hobbies whatever so
that's why I call it the ace method
that's tight appearance capability and
expansion yeah and um I think that's one
of the key things that I learned from
myself but I just got really lucky that
I learned that at a really young age
yeah because the first time I
experienced that was
um I think in martial arts so you know
when you're a kid and you're doing like
any traditional martial art Kung Fu
Taekwondo karate whatever
it's not really about beating someone
else they're not sparring it's about
forms right can you do the forms right
does it look good the appearance of it
so once that's where the a through F so
once you start doing stuff you're like
oh [__] that looks good like you could
tell when someone has snapped oh damn
that phone moves good then they're like
okay they look good now what's the
capability oh [__] it's gonna do a 360
kick oh this guy could do a backflip or
whatever and then you get a black belt
and I got one young got when I was like
10 years old you start to understand
every single thing in life has like five
or ten steps to get there and you know
you're gonna start a Wipeout at
everything and you're able to like
expand and apply this that's cool to
every single thing so even with like um
that's red that I think got
like I kind of had like a you know up
and down Journey got kicked out a bunch
of schools and all that stuff and I
think I got reacquainted with that
entire concept uh once I started lifting
weights seriously again because after
high school or after boot camp when I
lost all my all the muscle I built I was
like 130 again
I was I got to build back this muscle
started building back this muscle
started getting bigger when I did JK
like there's almost every comment oh I
share your workout program because I was
like one of the Jack dude only jacked
like Asian dudes out there share a
workout program share a workout program
so I had the appearance I felt jacked I
felt good
and then even in the commercial gyms I'm
like oh [__] I'm like the only one
deadlifting like five plates in here
like I feel pretty strong and so it was
like once again it kind of triggered the
whole thing like oh [__] like you look
good
then you can move and feel good and then
I don't know how to apply it yeah to
something else that's really rad yeah
and then that's why I like that that
whole phrase like confidence is built
and it's built by little wins yeah
because if you if your confidence isn't
proven then it's delusional right right
it's like the guy at the bar oh [__]
everyone yeah until he gets [__]
until he [__] around and finds out yeah
and then you just have some other guy
that also doesn't know how to fight
throw a lucky swing boom enough was out
right and then so that's delusional he
thinks he can whip everyone's ass yeah
not until he's really tested yeah but
when you fight like a guy that's like
season an MMA or Jiu Jitsu or whatever
like you might not even want to fight
they're so chill because they've been
through it yeah and I learned I guess I
learned that again also in wrestling too
because in wrestling
um you see guys that look very
physically intimidating you're like oh
[__] this fool got a tattoo on his face
or whatever yeah and then but you find
out real quick what people are made of
when you're you know tap hands yeah
because the minute you roll you're like
oh this guy doesn't know how to wrestle
at all or you meet a small little do you
like I'm gonna crush this [__]
and you're flying through the air you're
like what the like you find out real
quick so it's almost like I don't even
need my eyes I don't need to see how
badass you are we're going to tap hands
and we're going to figure out real quick
like where each other is at yeah and um
I think that's like where you have to
build your confidence because
when you have that like that deep
knowledge of Jiu Jitsu or deep knowledge
of business or deep knowledge of
whatever like you like right now like
when I talk to all of my friends about
business I actually like surprised
myself yeah because we're in the
day-to-day of our business you know and
like so we're always dealing with
problems and there's a lot of times you
don't know if you're doing the right
thing right when you start speaking with
other people oh [__] I'm actually like
um almost all businesses have the same
cycle everyone has year One problems and
you know then year five everyone has a
cash flow problems year six everyone has
HR problems like you're seven eight two
everyone has like in it you almost go
like every single business have the same
Cycles almost the same yearly problems
across the board yeah it's just how well
people have been able to manage that to
have that exponential growth but even
people that have the exponential growth
when I talk to them they still have
those problems just this time's bigger
yeah you know yeah it's still there yeah
because you think like oh we're a seven
figure business I talk to people nine
figure businesses they still got HR
problems or whatever problems but now
it's a whole department that they have a
problem with yeah
um yeah I know when I was talking it
sounded like I had this like no
confidence in things when you're younger
yeah like in the beginning yeah um but
it was definitely you know as I was
listening to you speak I was like well I
think also being the middle child helped
me a lot because it helped me be um
self-sustained like I could I could I
was self-sustainable and I think that
created the biggest foundation for me to
have this confidence right so I like the
confidence in when it came to business
but when I started doing the better
self-talk then at that point I started
really looking back at all my victories
and my wins and kind of where I started
to where I am now and going oh [__] like
hey chill out [__] like you're actually
pretty cool well what's crazy is
recently we were in Texas and we're uh
interviewing some like High Caliber
people
and one of the common things was they
were all middle children by Tim
Kennedy's a middle child Nikki Rodriguez
middle child and I was like oh [__] like
there's this thing about uh having to
like maybe prove yourself or fend for
yourself for your more independent at an
early age and you that Independence
transforms into if I want this life no
one's going to give it to me gotta grab
it for myself and I think the earlier
someone understands that the earlier
they take control of their life instead
of the life happens to them 100 and
that's what was happening with me
bomb but because I didn't have the the
positive relationship with myself yeah I
wasn't highlighting those things and I
wasn't
um uh I wasn't cheering those things on
for myself because yeah I look back at
it now and I'm like dude that's really
rad like you can't move forward or
succeed if you don't have a type of
confidence in yourself
you know but because at a very early age
I just knew that I had to make it happen
for myself and it was more subconscious
it wasn't like I pinpointed it and it's
like Geo if you want this you gotta get
after it it was literally like okay I
don't really see that it's gonna happen
for me with you know my parents or my
brother and sister so it's like what do
I want well I guess I just have to do it
and I didn't know that that was uncommon
yeah yeah I just thought that's just the
way it is
by feeling yeah big broad strokes and
it's not until in retrospect you like
are able to articulate precisely what is
happening yeah but if you can recognize
that you're doing that for yourself and
know that you have to make your path
happen that's when the confidence really
really comes at you really fast because
you're just like well wait this stuff
can't be taken away from me because
that's true confidence now you know yeah
um kind of like the the the the the what
did I say the box that I created for
myself to stand on yeah that's what it
was like because it's like now I can
really support myself and I have these
tools
um and that's when confidence really
happened for me when I can recognize all
my little victories because it's like
like you said life doesn't happen at you
it's like you have to go out and get it
and every time you you make a stride in
that direction to be like I don't like
this about my life or myself you and you
change it and you're able to positively
change it then that's where the
confidence starts coming up that's one
of my favorite things about Western
philosophy versus Eastern philosophy so
like Eastern philosophy there's like and
there's pros and cons to both I'm not
saying what's better than the other but
for this specific topic
Eastern philosophy it almost feels like
competition
um the result of it is for legacy
so it's very like did you win yes
Quan family now has honor right so it's
a very like Legacy based thing
what I like about Western philosophy of
competition is
after we go at it
whoever wins
um actually doesn't get to learn very
much the loser gets to learn a bunch of
stuff they get to improve on so they can
go back and improve yeah and then they
get to come back either the same person
or a different person go at it again so
you're using competition as a way to
figure out what your holes are yeah and
so you'll see that's the reason why a
lot of the more Western like not just
ethnically and culturally but even even
like Asian cultures that are more
Western culture inclined that have that
competitive Spirit they go up because
you know different companies will
compete Microsoft Apple and Alban and
they create a great product like every
company they compete and they create
this huge good product and that's why I
really like competition and it's not
viewed as like uh like if you come home
and someone lost it's not like oh man he
lost it's just more okay cool you have
to work on now and some of the best
competitors that I meet
they don't look at it like oh they lost
or they won it was just more like what
did you what were you able to learn I
feel like that's such a new thing
I feel like that's something that you
know our generation really started
zeroing I think we brought that back
because if you look at the old Greek
stuff the reason why they had Olympics
wrestling and why they like to debate
they knew iron sharpens iron back in the
day so like even back in the day like uh
people that like so like the ties right
the Muay Thai like guys they they
adopted this Western philosophy so they
want the best like they don't want okay
this guy's the king let's give him like
a bunch of fresh meat he just whoops
everyone's ass he's not getting any
better like I want to bring someone else
that's gonna hurt me a lot so that we
can train and I make him better he makes
me better and then now me and this guy
are leagues above everyone else because
we made each other better and you find
that in almost like um every Circle you
know whether it's like
crypto Academia wherever like you find
like if you can get a bunch of people
that can debate compete and challenge
the ideas is it actually good and then
that's how you were able to build more
and more and more and more yeah that's
what I'm such a big fan of like
competitions and challenges because like
like even with like power lifting or
running a marathon it's like you're
doing it for yourself
and uh you build your own confidence for
yourself and like when I ran my first
marathon
but there's times in my brain I want to
quit
but you actually learn stuff about
yourself yeah oh [__] you know what even
when both of my quads and both of my
hamstrings are cramping
I'm still down to keep going yeah and
you don't actually know if you have the
dog in you until you're put into a dog
fight of course right you know and then
you're like oh [__] I actually do I'm
very proud of myself you know yeah yeah
and that's one of the things too one of
the key factors
um that helped me have real confidence
in my abilities is getting into the
fight
right because it's like you have to put
yourself in uncomfortable situations in
order to find out what you're made out
of yeah and it wasn't until I started
really getting into more and more
uncomfortable situations specific to
business
um where I'm like [__] dude like this is
so bad like I don't need to be here I
don't want to feel like this I feel like
I'm drowning I feel like I don't know
what I'm doing like [__] I hate it but
little by little you just keep chipping
away at it and you're like oh damn okay
I have a better handle on this thing
okay everything else is [__] up but
okay fine at least this little pocket of
this I can put that away and I'm good
okay now the next pocket and then the
more you keep like digging away and
chipping away at it you're like oh damn
I have all this stuff that I'm very
comfortable with that now and that that
for sure was key to my my newfound
confidence in myself it was freaking
cool to seeing you follow the ace method
and see a new holiday that's amazing
like you smash of that business and I
can literally see like when you're
mothering I'm like this is the mother
the mothering skills of a CEO why like
the way that you like structure taika's
like before school activities after
school activities
um how he reads the sight words how he
does chores and even recently you
started like teaching about Finance
you're like okay I'm gonna give you like
however much money every week and then
you're gonna have you choose how to use
it spending pile savings pile or helping
others pile and we're going to make a
balance sheet so you can keep track like
that's like a CEO that's CUNY I didn't
even think about it you know but that's
like a CEO's mind like you've been able
to do it for yourself
so that you can expand it and apply it
to others around you know because it's
like it's like if you're um
like fat and lazy as a parent how are
you gonna teach your kids not to be that
way right that's so hard so it's like
um you have to walk the walk yeah so
like being able to see you do that has
been really really cool like I'll see
you just like these little things and
I'm like oh that's a CEO Raising a Son
thank you yeah yeah it was a lot of it
was a lot of work but again you know no
one else is going to do it for you it's
like whatever it is that you want you
can have it for sure the world is your
oyster they weren't kidding when you
said that like anything you want you can
have it it's just you have to be willing
to put in the work and and through
putting in the work and failing learning
those lessons sharpening your tools and
then going at it again that's what
creates true confidence and I think
maybe it had to take me this long for me
to really realize it because I felt like
the other confidence that I had yeah it
was good
um but to certain degrees it felt a
little bit uh superficial for me
like which one like the the the beauty
standard one right one of the first ones
that I had
um and then moving on on my own like
that one was great but it wasn't until I
was put into more of the business
mindset but those are baby steps
together for sure 100 and we all need to
go through stuff like that right yeah
um but
knowing that I could build my own world
that is a confidence booster like no
other and you don't have to necessarily
go into business to build your own world
like you can do that within your family
structure you can do that within your
own life if you're a single person and
you want to remain that way right it's
like well what does your circle look
like what does your home look like what
is your work your your environment at
your workplace look like what type of
work are you turning in like how are you
spending your free time like this is
still a world that you're creating yeah
like is it allowing you to grow and
Thrive and learn
um then yeah you're pretty [__]
successful and you should find a lot of
confidence in that yeah but if your
world consists of like inconsistent
friends and you know shaky foundation
with your family members or like your
finances are a little bit [__] and
you're at a dead-end job that you're not
really happy at and any spare time that
you have you're spending it [__]
getting drunk you know your world is
pretty [__] and I can't really see you
building a lot of confidence coming out
of a space like that so it doesn't
necessarily have to apply to
entrepreneurship or a business but it's
just whatever world you want to create
for yourself yeah that's one of the
things I look back and I'm like damn
some kids had it figured out early for
example
like you know like the stereotypical
like quarterback of the football team
with the 4.0 that's also ASB president
oh right you know I'm like some people
been building their own worlds young
where I was probably just lost in the
sauce I don't know what the [__] was
going on I'm like why is that person
like even volunteering I don't know like
what the [__] I just want to go smoke
weed you know and you're like and you're
like damn I look back on my man some
people
have they knew what they wanted they
started building the world early and
they're already making high school their
oyster yeah they probably didn't feel
like they needed to survive in the
beginning
possibly yeah you know because I think
you and I felt like we needed some type
of survival yeah or we needed to like
keep our head above water to be like
okay what the [__] is going on yeah yeah
and then like figure it out from there
where some of these kids not to stay
there in a super healthy environment but
at least they felt like they were
um in a position enough to be comfy
enough to make decisions for themselves
and feel like there's a type of support
system yeah
where I can't say that for myself yeah
that's why I'm so happy we put type in
so many things like when he's young yeah
because like when he hit seven he would
have done Jiu Jitsu for three years now
which seven is still young right so I
could totally see like another brand new
seven-year-old because you're barely
first second grade and you go sign up
for jiu jitsu and then that's like the
first time and it all intimidated and
someone who's already done it for three
years I could totally see attacker going
oh don't worry come on I'll help you
yeah excuse me and that's how people get
started so young and they kind of
already starting to make their world
their oyster like type of scene like oh
what that kid got two stripes that kid
has a gray belt like he can just slowly
see all these little things building
yeah yeah it really matters
um the type of involvement you have with
your kids like I see how and I don't
know if it's because he's smart but I
assume because he feels like he's still
an average kid like he doesn't feel like
he's like just genius no he's not feel
like a genius
um
that came from [__] that came from
your heart
um but I can see with just my
involvement and our attention with him
whether that be just to kind of play
with him for 10 minutes or just do 20
minutes of reading and allowing him to
read or just listening to his stories
his confidence and and his ability to
retain these things I just see it
growing exponentially you know and it
makes me think and again that this is
not me throwing any type of shade to my
upbringing or my parents I know they
[__] did their best and I love them
so much and I don't see any fault in
what they did but I didn't have that you
know my mom was trying to make an ends
meet so was my dad so like I was left
alone quite a bit I wasn't necessarily a
latchkey kid but I was definitely alone
a lot of the time so I didn't have
someone sitting at the table helping me
with my homework you know it was more
like hey did you do your homework good
here let's have dinner okay get ready
for bed let's go you know it was one of
those things yeah and I'm sure if I had
someone there holding my hand and like
you know okay let's read this word let's
work out this problem or hey you know
like just giving me some type of um
feedback I I could see myself turning
out completely different yeah something
my uncle always talks about so my uncle
was first generation like doctor
and um he said like he pretty much took
like the Taiwanese MCAT like five times
before he made it and he had to work so
[__] hard and he goes man when you
have a classmate and their older
siblings already went to the best
college or passed the Taiwanese MCAT
whatever he goes it's so easy for them
yeah so for him like that's what I think
he wants all of his kids to be in the
medical field because he cannot yeah he
can he can help them with that he can
help them with that and that's one of
the things that like actually motivated
me to be a high performer not so much
even for myself to have a good life but
you can't pass on tools if like
like everyone loves their kid right
everyone loves your kid and they want
the best for their kid but how does that
manifest
do you love them enough to make yourself
a high performer so you can pass on
those tools so they can be a high
performer or do you only love them to
your comfort level where you're not
willing to expand where you're at and
they're just gonna be yeah I don't think
people I don't think a lot of us would
think like that in the moment yeah but
from every time I hit like a hard
competition or whatever I'm like you
know what that's really cool like now I
can pass this piece of information
nugget or Insight onto young types yeah
and he'll believe me right because it's
not like my parents telling me I should
be a doctoral [__] you and a
doctor why you telling me to be a doctor
for that's true you know what I mean
like my mom if my mom's like Oh you
should work for a shipping company I'm
like oh yeah that makes sense you've
been working shipping conversation you
get it I get it yeah my dad telling me
to be a card dealer I should be a car
dealer that's what you do yeah yeah yeah
but they're telling me well they're
reasoning I'm sure they're like because
we want you to do better than us
obviously it makes sense yeah but it
doesn't stick yeah you don't like taika
we don't even tell no workout and he
[__] loves working out because he
sees us working out all the time that's
true yeah he wants big muscles he says
CUNY guy well damn this is uh this was
some insightful stuff
um I don't know if I was able to share a
lot of it I feel like I was kind of
scattered all over the place
um but that's very relatable it's
because
um I think most people it seems like you
know from at least from a lot of the
questions and comments that we get
people they like they they feel lost or
they feel like they're they're lacking
confidence and they want to go like how
how can I do it like they want to they
want to improve and take control of
their life and yeah um I think whatever
you shared is definitely going to help
help yeah long story short it's normal
to not have this confidence you know but
it's uh it's it's on you to
look at look at yourself and be like
what don't you like where do you want to
be and then work at those things and
then once you've accomplished it it
doesn't have to be big crazy goals but
just once you've accomplished it you're
like you need to recognize it and be
like I did that [__] and that's when the
true confidence starts coming in
on that note is there anything else you
want to add Barton nope just want to say
that if you like this podcast and you
want to support everything that me and
geodo go to Barbara brigade.com always
drop me supplements apparel digital
training programs and also we have a gym
in Downtown LA 646 Gibbons uh go check
that out see you guys next time bye